You are looking at an HTML document, and
this is what this document
looks like inside the browser.
The similarities should
be pretty obvious.
You can see this is a heading
here inside the HTML, and
you can see the same, this is
a heading here inside the browser.
There's a lot here.
But I don't want you to
worry about everything.
Right now just pay attention
to what you see right here,
which is coming inside these two tags.
That's a body.
This thing right here with , this is
a heading, and is an HTML element.
And this is a special kind of
element called h1 element.
H stands for heading, and
one means it's the biggest.
That means that there are h2,
h3, h4 tags and so on, and
they're all smaller then each one.
Specifically, this part is called a tag,
the part with an angle bracket h1,
and then another angle bracket.
There are many tags in HTML.
Here's a p tag, here are some span tags,
and this is an image tag.
Each one of these represents
a different kind of element.
This p, inside this tag,
stands for paragraph.
This whole thing is called
a paragraph element.
Notice that this whole element
has two tags, here and here, and
these tags are slightly different.
There's an opening tag, and
there is a closing tag, and
notice the closing tag
has the slash in it.
Between the opening and
the closing tag comes the content.
This content is generally what
people will see inside the browser.
So here are a few different elements.
Notice that the text in both
tags is always the same.
And notice that they all
start with a less than sign,
they all have some kind of text in here
indicating what type of element this is,
and then every tag has
a greater than sign.
And just to point it out again, closing
tags have a slash inside them, but
otherwise they look the same.
And the slash always comes right
here after the less than sign.
And then together,
everything here represents an element.
There are some elements, like images,
that are slightly different.
Notice that images do
not have a closing tag.
And that's okay.
It's a special one that you'll
learn more about later.
This is a conceptual way of
representing the same element.
In this case,
the content belongs to the paragraph.
The content in a way is
a child of the paragraph.
This is going to be useful later.
Don't worry about it now,
but I just wanted to show you because
you'll be seeing more trees like this.
For the time being, I want you to
write your first HTML element.